[Musique]
connaissez-vous le point commun entre un
vaisseau spatial une voiture électrique
une pyramide la réhabilitation d'une
maison classée ou la mise en place d'une
ferme aquacole en guadeloupe
aucun de ses 5 initiative n'aurait pu
voir le jour sans la gestion de
management de projets solidement ficelé
alors nous vivons dans un monde
aujourd'hui où le déséquilibre est la
caractéristique majeure au niveau
économique mais paradoxalement on
s'aperçoit qu'on a de plus en plus
d'opportunités commerciales de plus en
plus en plus importante
à une condition toutefois c'est d'être
capable de transformer toutes ces idées
d'innovation notamment en projet
réellement faisable durable est
réalisable alors j'étais à me poser la
question souvent on me disait en tant
que lobbyiste gouvernements en afrique
madame d'agneau il ya des déchets dans
la lagune comment peut-on faire pour
financer ses opérations
porteurs de projets en guadeloupe
nous avons deux projets de mettre en
place tel hôpital tel ehpad d'apporter
des solutions pour les personnes âgées
comment peut-on faire pour trouver des
financements
de l'autre côté les financiers me dise
ce projet manque de l'innovation
compétitivité où est la valeur ajoutée
et je me suis dit il y as forcément des
points communs puisque le projet reste
quelque chose qui vise à simplement
apporter quelque chose pour la cité au
sens grec du terme
nul besoin d'être un bâtisseur de
cathédrale pour envisager de mettre en
oeuvre un projet que ce soit des projets
de grande envergure sur plusieurs années
ou des petits projets il ya forcément
des dénominateurs communs pour permettre
désormais d'avoir des projets qui
fonctionne j'entendais souvent oui mais
je n'ai pas été financés parce que mon
projet ne fonctionne pas le modèle
économique des mots qui paraissent
complexes mais nous avons tous à un
moment un mode dans notre vie de la
vraie volonté d'apporter des choses
vous êtes tous des porteurs de projets
et l'objectif c'est de pouvoir
aujourd'hui apporter des vraies
solutions des méthodes qui nous
permettent de s'assurer que ces projets
pourront se développer pour quoi pour
qu'on se pose la question aujourd'hui la
guadeloupe est dans une démarche de
médiation de la compétitivité a prévu de
réduire le taux du chômage d'apporter
des nouvelles solutions sur des secteurs
économiques classiques l'hôtellerie le
tourisme la pêche la culture est aussi
de pouvoir découvrir des nouveaux
secteurs
la digitalisation l'été c'est qu'ils
sont des mots qui paraît sperber mais
qui sont une vraie réalité alors comment
faire aujourd'hui pour pouvoir apporter
des solutions qui permettent de vous de
nous d'avoir des projets durables
j'aime bien la citation de victor hugo
qui dit rien n'est plus puissant qu'un
projet qui arrive à temps et on ne
pourra pas le contredire ce soir sur ce
sujet et je me suis dit finalement c'est
comme un jeu un jeu est composé de quoi
hein j'ai composé d'éléments un jeu est
composé de règles 1 j'ai composé
essentiellement de l'action du jeu alors
quand on prend tous ces paramètres on
s'aperçoit d'une chose que finalement ce
sont les ingrédients indispensables pour
pouvoir jouer alors quand on joue il ya
trois catégories de joueurs la première
catégorie c'est le joueur qui connaît
les règles qui connaît le jeu et
maîtrise des règles du jeu donc
généralement beaucoup plus de chances de
gagner le jeu la deuxième catégorie de
joueurs celle qui connaît le jeu mais
qui ne maîtrisent pas les règles et qui
souvent a plus de chance de perdre face
à l'adversaire la troisième catégorie de
joueurs celui qui connaît le jeu mais
qui ne maîtrisent pas les règles et qui
avance en tâtonnant sur le jeu avec la
seule crainte de la fin du jeu puisque
souvent il a beaucoup d'occasions de
perdre alors avec tous ces éléments là
je me suis dit mais finalement
effectivement c'est comme un jeu
d'échecs
quand on a un projet il ya forcément des
dénominateurs communs qui nous permette
de pouvoir toujours s'assurer qu'on a le
minimum pour pouvoir gagner en
maîtrisant les règles du jeu alors
prenons trois jetons essentiel en le
jetant numéro un votre projet notre
projet le projet s'est coincé se
projeter en avant m quelque chose en
passe apporter quelque chose à la cité
alors désormais ce que je vous invite à
faire quand vous envisagerez d'avoir des
projets qu'ils soient petits ou grands
tous secteurs d'activité confondus
penser le projet comme une maison ma
maison sera t'elle petites ou grandes
mon projet sera-t-il petit ou grand
combien ça va coûter
est-ce suffisamment d'argent pour cela
et puis quand je mettrai mon projet
quand j'aurai ma maison où je me situe
qui suis-je qu'est ce que j'apporte
qu'est-ce que ça va changer pour moi et
pour les autres
le jeton numéro deux innovations mot à
la mode et qui pourtant est un point
essentiel dans le jeu pour ceux qui
veulent gagner en tout cas alors
l'innovation peut être une innovation
technologique très souvent ou une
innovation de procédés de service ou
innovation sociale ce sont souvent les
trois paramètres que l'on retrouve dans
l'innovation et bien souvent cette pièce
manque dans les règles du jeu dans les
projets que l'on voit aujourd'hui
alors règle numéro 2 qu'on retiendra
avec ce jeton quand on fait des projets
cherchait toujours à démontrer ce que
vous apportez de plus alors l'innovation
c'est pas forcément créer quelque chose
de nouveau c'est simplement améliorer
l'existant changer le prisme de ce qui
existe déjà et là on devient innovant
qu'est ce que j'apporte de plus
troisième jetons de notre jeu la
compétitivité mots en apparence complet
et pourtant ô combien essentielle alors
la compétitivité sont de vela définir
très simplement
c'est simplement quoi c'est sur un
territoire donné une zone géographique
donnée
on va prendre donc la guadeloupe fournir
des biens ou des services durablement
avec un modèle économique qui permet de
générer de l'activité dans un milieu
concurrentiel ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que je ne suis pas le seul
ça c'est la compétitivité aujourd'hui
dans le monde dans lequel nous nous
situerons c'est la course à la
compétitivité qui est le plus compétitif
mais ça veut dire quoi pour la
guadeloupe aujourd'hui ça veut dire quoi
pour nous nous sommes dans des secteurs
d'activité en plein développement
il y a des nouveaux sujets comme la
biodiversité comme l'aquaculture il y a
plein de thématiques sont aujourd'hui il
y a des opportunités sur le sujet alors
souvent on utilise l'étroitesse du
marché local pour justifier le manque de
compétitivité
mais je pense aujourd'hui en observant
les porteurs de projets que j'accompagne
quotidiennement que ça soit on les
petits porteurs de projets ou certains
gouvernements qu'ils y a un corollaire
qu'on oublie très souvent ça pourrait
être le chasser en meute un terme
consacré par ailleurs qui vise à dire
quoi apprenons de plus en plus à
concevoir nos projets de telle sorte à
mutualiser un certain nombre d'éléments
ne jouons pas seuls dans notre coin ne
pensons pas déjà que souvent nous allons
seuls l'idée pensé qu' il n'y a pas
d'autres personnes autour de vous et
combien
vous auriez des concurrents que la
concurrence vous met face à face
en réalité la compétitivité c'est autre
chose c'est justement se dire
suis-je dans un océan bleu c'est à dire
je suis le seul face à la mer et
j'avance sur le marché où je suis dans
un océan rouge il ya plein d'acteurs
autour de moi la compétitivité permet de
pouvoir créer de la valeur qu'est ce que
je crée en plus que celui qui est à côté
de moi et puis ça nécessite autre chose
quand vous concevez vos projets règle
numéro 3 qui suis-je au regard de
l'écosystème de mon projet suis-je un
pionner sujet un acteur classique mais
qui apporte un service complémentaire ou
justement suis complètement en avance de
montant donc ce sont ces trois
paramètres qui aujourd'hui sont des
éléments essentiels pour pouvoir mettre
en place des projets performant et
durable alors je vous propose que l'on
puisse jouer avec nos trois jetons
prenons le jeton numéro 1 un projet je
vous propose que l'on prenne la création
d'une ferme aquacole dont les outre mer
un projet actuellement que j'ai le
plaisir de pouvoir mener
rappelez-vous nous avons dix projets
maison où je vais mettre ma maison je
vous propose que nous allions à saint
louis à marie galante
pour ceux qui connaissent le projet vise
à mettre en place créer une ferme
agricole pour pouvoir produire des
huîtres des huîtres en guadeloupe
huîtres local tout de suite
jetons numéro 2 qu'est ce que ça change
qu'est ce que ça apporte
où est l'innovation innovations
technologiques
réfléchissons oui certainement
pourquoi parce que jusqu'à maintenant
produire des huîtres dans de l'eau
chaude n'a jamais existé
donc en france nous avons des fermes
aquacoles qui font des huîtres mais pas
dans les eaux des outre-mer donc on est
dans de l'innovation technologique on
deuxième jetons donc je le tiens
troisième jetons compétitivité en quoi
mettre en place une ferme aquacole de
production d'huîtres à marie galante
contribuer à la compétitivité de la
guadeloupe à améliorer quoi la
visibilité de la performance
effectivement mise en place d'une
filière création d'emplois potentialités
de mettre en place de la formation pour
des nouveaux métiers autour de la
biodiversité
et puis la petite touche c'est que saint
louis est toute petite superficie une
toute petite île et on est sur une
thématique qui permet d'intégrer les
pêcheurs déjà existants donc on leur
apporte une extension de leurs activités
création de valeur rejoint une deuxième
fois
cette fois ci allons sur la pratique de
la sargasse entre projet que j'ai le
plaisir d'accompagner également sur le
territoire aujourd'hui la problématique
de la serre gas fait que nous avons des
solutions intermédiaires qui ne sont pas
performantes
on reprend jetons numéro le projet le
projet consiste à trouver une solution
par rapport à la problématique de la
cerda ce qu'est ce qu'on en fait comment
on fait pour réduire les services
donc on réfléchit on va mettre en place
des acteurs qui vont récolter qui vont
ensuite traités ensuite qu'ils vont
valoriser cette sergas transformer la
nuisance aquatiques en une opportunité
je tends numéro deux dans ce jeu serait
s'agace où est l'innovation
l'innovation dans ce sujet là pour notre
jeu se situe à deux niveaux en
innovation technologique puisqu'on a des
technologies qui vont arriver pour
récolter la sérieuse traiter la sergas
valoriser l'innovation de procéder
certainement puisque aujourd'hui les
technologies existantes n'apporte pas la
solution d'une manière durable est
également innovation sociale au sens de
l'ex de l'économie sociale et solidaire
puisque on mettrait en place une filière
qui permettrait d'inclure l'ensemble des
acteurs concernés par la problématique
je tends numéro 3 compétitivité
compétitivité qui veut dire travailler
ensemble avec l'ensemble des partenaires
concernés
je suis un petit porteur de projet qui
met en place des mécanismes pour
ramasser la sargasse je suis une
entreprise qui fait de la valorisation
de déchets comment nous nous rencontrons
pour structurer une filière et rendre
quoi la guadeloupe compétitive tout
simplement sur sa capacité de pouvoir
gérer ses problèmes de biodiversité
alors finalement je me suis aperçu que
en fonctionnant comme ça j'avais la
fierté et la joie de pouvoir accompagner
les projets toujours en étendant la
passerelle des financiers qui reste
l'enjeu je fais des projets il ya
toujours un coût et pour pouvoir les
séduire s'il toujours gagné dans notre
jeu avoir des projets conçus d'une
manière durable et performante
un projet bien pensé comme une maison
bien pensé avec des caractéristiques
d'innovation qui sont simplement une
façon de présenter votre projet
pas forcément de créer d'une manière
toujours nouvelle je change le prisme et
démontrer qu'il ya de la compétitivité
c'est à dire de la valeur je crée de la
valeur
alors quand on a dit tout ça on
s'aperçoit simplement
les choses sont quand même beaucoup plus
simple et qu'il suffit bien souvent de
pouvoir prendre le temps de poser ses
bases minimum pour pouvoir avoir des
ports des projets durables et performant
alors pour ceux qui jouent aux échecs et
infinite j'ai envie de dire que lorsque
l'on commence à mettre en oeuvre un
projet l'essentiel c'est de pouvoir
faire et chaque émeute
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]